WITH KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JESSE WATTERS, JUAN WILLIAMS AND
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
IT WAS A SITCOM WITHOUT THE
SERMON.
>> HOW COULD YOU HAVE VOTED FOR
HIM, ROSEANNE?
>> HE TALKED ABOUT JOBS, JACKIE.
HE SAID HE WOULD SHAKE THINGS
UP.
THIS MIGHT COME AS A SHOCK TO
YOU BUT WE ALMOST LOST OUR
HOUSE.
>> NOW THINGS ARE WORSE.
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE NEWS?
>> NOT AT THE REAL NEWS.
>> WHAT A DISASTER IT WOULD BE.
I GO IN THE BOOTH AND I VOTED
FOR JILL STEIN.
>> WHO IS JILL STEIN?
>> SOME DOCTOR.
>> Greg: PERFECT.
THE ROSEANN REBOOT AIRED.
18 MILLION PEOPLE WATCHED.
SORRY, STORMY.
THIS OTHER TRUMP WOMAN TROUNCED
HER INTERVIEW.
I WATCHED THE SHOW.
IT WAS MESSY AND ROBERT WAS ALSO
FUNNY.
MEANING IT WAS HUMAN.
EACH CHARACTER WAS LIKABLE BUT
FLAWED, THE ANTI-TRUMPER WAS
IRRATIONAL.
THE PRO-TRUMP-ERI WAS
SLOGANEERING.
HILLARY WAS OFF HER SAINTLY
PERCH.
>> ON JACKIE THINGS EVERY GIRL
SHOULD GROW UP TO BE PRESIDENT
IF AND IF THEY ARE A LIAR, LIAR,
PANTSUIT ON FIRE.
>> I THINK WE KNOW WHO IS A LIAR
AND WHO IS ON FIRE.
>> Greg: WISES SO REFRESHING?
PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE FOR A REAL
REFLECTION OF THE POLITICAL
DISCUSSION MINUS THE BIAS.
LEFT AND RIGHT WERE PRESENT BUT
NEITHER WERE BASED ON THEIR --
IN ROSEANNE'S WORLD,
DISAGREEMENT DOESN'T TAKE YOU AN
ENEMY.
SHE FOUND A WAY TO SHRINK THE
POLITICAL TRIBALISM, REPLACING
DEMONIZATION WITH DIALOGUE WHICH
MEANS IT CAN ONLY UPSET THOSE
WHO NEED DIVISION TO KEEP THEIR
FADING NAME IN PLAY.
MEANING TOM ARNOLD.
YES, AFTER I TWEETED ABOUT THE
SHOW, SAYING IT'S THE MOST
HONEST ASSESSMENT OF RECENT
TIMES THAT ISN'T FOUND IN YOUR
OWN HOUSE, THE HAS BEEN USED AND
ANGRY FINGER TO TWEET "WE SURE
AS F ARE GOING TO FIND IT AT
GREG GUTFELD, FOX NEWS.
I DON'T KNOW TOM BUT WE ALL KNOW
IF TOM, A FADED RELIC LASHES OUT
AT THE MERE THOUGHT OF A EX
DOING WELL.
IF YOU ARE UPSET SOMEONE IS
SUCCESSFUL, IT'S BECAUSE YOU
AREN'T.
PLAY NICE, TOM, MAYBE YOU'LL
SCORE A BIT PART AS A WASHED UP
COMIC.
SEE HOW NICE I AM?
I PLUGGED HIS GIG IN APRIL.
>> Dana: HE REALLY HAS ONE.
>> Greg: APRIL 29.
TOM, YOU OWE ME THAT.
THIS IS, 18.2 MILLION VIEWERS.
A HIGHER DEMOGRAPHIC THAN STORMY
A HIGHER DEMOGRAPHIC THAN STORM
STORMY.
>> Dana: IT IS A NEWS SHOW
VERSUS A SITCOM BUT OKAY, FINE.
>> Greg: DON'T LAUGH AT MY
COMPARISONS OR I WILL SKIP YOU
AND GO TO JESSE.
>> Dana: I AM NOT LAUGHING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kimberly: FAVORABLE
AUDIENCE WITH THIS GUY.
>> Jesse: HAS SHE BEEN
SKIPPED?
>> Dana: I LOVED ROSEANNE WHEN
I WAS GROWING UP.
I GUESS I WAS A LOT OLDER THAN I
THINK I WAS AT THE TIME.
I LOVED WATCHING IT.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I GREW UP IN
A PART OF THE WORLD WHERE THIS
WAS A NORMAL FAMILY.
I KNEW PEOPLE WHO HAD FAMILIES
LIKE THIS.
MY FAMILY IS LIKE THIS A LITTLE
BIT.
I DID THINK IT WAS FUNNIER THAN
SATURN OR LIVE TASK
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" HAS BEEN
RECENTLY.
IT WAS AT LEAST MORE HONEST IN
ITS HUMOR.
I THOUGHT ONE PAYMENT WAS
INTERESTING ASIDE FROM THE
TRUMP-HILLARY STUFF WAS WHEN
THEY WERE AT THE TABLE AND HE
BRINGS HOME THE FACT OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND SAYS I
COULD ONLY GET HALF BECAUSE
THAT'S ALL I COULD AFFORD.
THEY MAKE A JOKE.
FIVE ANTI-INFLAMMATORIES IN FIVE
ANTIDEPRESSANTS.
THE COST OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
AND HEALTH CARE IS A BIG ISSUE
ESPECIALLY FOR BLUE-COLLAR OBAMA
VOTERS WHO VOTED FOR TRUMP.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS PRETTY
INTERESTING.
I WATCHED THE SECOND EPISODE AS
WELL.
>> Greg: 21 YEARS.
WORTH THE WAIT QUESTION YOU WERE
IN YOUR 30s.
>> Jesse: YEAH, THANK YOU.
THERE'S A FEW REASONS WHY IT WAS
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
ABC DID A GREAT JOB PLAYING THIS
OUT.
THEY HAVE BEEN PROMOTING THIS
FOR OVER A YEAR AND IT'S BEEN
SPECTACULAR.
THE ROLLOUT HAS BEEN VERY
SPECIAL.
I LIKE HAVING TO PREP FOR
"THE FIVE" BY WATCHING TV.
DOESN'T GET ANY BETTER THAN
THAT.
I REALLY SWEAT IT ALL OUT.
I WATCH THE FIRST HALF HOUR AND
I THOUGHT IT WAS ACCESSIBLE TO
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS.
LIKE YOU SAID, THEY ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE COST OF
PERCEPTION MEDICATION.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE HAD TO MOVE
BACK IN WITH HER PARENTS BECAUSE
YOU GOT FIRED.
THE FATHER HAS A GUN IN THE
HOUSE.
IT'S A STRESSFUL KIND OF LOWER
MIDDLE-CLASS BACKGROUND WHICH
HAS BEEN DIFFERENT BECAUSE OVER
THE YEARS, YOU'VE SEEN SITCOM
FAMILIES GROW RICHER AND RICHER
AND RICHER WHILE THE AVERAGE
FAMILY IN AMERICA STAYS THE
SAME.
THAT WAS NICE THAT NOT EVERYBODY
HAD A $3,000 SUIT AND LIVED IN A
PENTHOUSE IN MANHATTAN.
ALSO GOOD WAS THEY HAVE THE
GENDER BENDING SON AND THE
DEBATE OVER BEING A SURROGATE.
USUALLY THOSE TOPICS IN NETWORK
SITCOMS ARE CELEBRATED.
THEY ARE NORMALIZED.
IN THIS CASE, PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH IT, AND THEY ARE
GRAPPLING WITH IT BUT THEY ARE
DOING IT WITH HUMOR AND THEY ARE
DOING IT IN AN OPEN-MINDED WAY.
I THINK THAT'S THE REALITY TO
90% OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE WOMAN'S MARCHING SISTER WITH
THE PINK HAT, THE NASTY WOMAN,
IT'S FANTASTIC.
IT IS VERY BALANCED BECAUSE THIS
IS THE ONLY TIME YOU HAVE SEEN
THE CONSERVATIVE PROTAGONIST
WHERE SHE IS NOT MOCKED ON
NETWORK TELEVISION.
LEE'S SISTER GETS IT RIGHT BACK
TO ROSEANNE.
I THOUGHT THE JOKES WERE
RELEVANT AND PRETTY CUTTING
EDGE.
OBAMACARE JOKES, PANTSUIT JOKES,
RUSSIAN JOKES, FAKE NEWS JOKES.
EVEN THE NONPOLITICAL JOKES, THE
TIMING WAS GOOD AND THE COMEDY
WRITING IS GOOD.
THE BOTTOM LINE I BELIEVE IS
THAT THE MESSAGE OF THE SHOW IS
THAT PEOPLE COME FROM DIFFERENT
POLITICAL BACKGROUNDS, AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HATE EACH OTHER.
YOU CAN TALK IT OUT AND YOU
DON'T ASSUME THAT THE OTHER
PERSON'S INTENTIONS ARE EVIL.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT WORK.
>> Greg: JUAN, THAT WAS THE
THING.
THERE IS SOMETHING REFRESHING
ABOUT IT IN THAT IT'S AN ATTEMPT
TO TRY TO INJECT CIVILITY INTO
KIND OF AN UNCIVIL TIME.
>> Juan: SURE.
IT'S GOOD THAT THESE PEOPLE
PRESENTED ON NATIONAL TV IN THIS
WAY.
TO ME, IT'S GOOD NEWS FOR
CONSERVATIVES.
I THINK CONSERVATIVES HAD ALWAYS
COMPLAINED I THINK ON THE SHOW,
KIMBERLY HAS SAID WISE IN THEIR
LATE-NIGHT TALK SHOW FOR
CONSERVATIVES.
HERE WE HAVE A SITCOM FOR
CONSERVATIVES FOR THEM TO SAY
HEY, THAT'S A REFLECTION OF OUR
VALUES AND WHO WE ARE.
I THINK IT'S A VERY NICE
REPRESENTATION IN THIS SENSE,
I'M NOT SURE MOST TRUMP PEOPLE
WOULD BE ACCEPTING OF THAT SONG,
FOR EXAMPLE.
AND I LOVED THE JOKE ABOUT JILL
STEIN.
I KNOW PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
PEOPLE WHO SAY I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT HILLARY SO I VOTED FOR
JILL STEIN.
YOU WASTED A VOTE IN
NORTH CAROLINA FOR JILL STEIN?
OH, MY GOD.
TO >> Greg: DEMOCRATS BELIEVE
JILL STEIN BECAUSE THE ELECTION.
>> Juan: I DO KNOW THAT SHE
COST THE ELECTION BUT SHE
DRAINED -- TO ME IT'S CRAZY.
I THINK --
>> Kimberly: HAS SHE BEEN
SPEAKING TO THE RUSSIANS?
THERE IS THE COLLUSION FOR YOU.
THEY ARE BARKING UP THE WRONG
TREE.
>> Juan: WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE PEOPLE TALK, I REALLY
AGREE WITH WHAT JESSE SAID.
THEY ARE ARGUING POLITICS IN
SUCH A WAY THAT IT'S REFRESHING
THAT THEY HAVEN'T TALKED FOR
YEARS, THE SET UP FOR THIS, THE
SISTERS HAVEN'T TALKED FOR YEARS
AND THE SISTER COMES BACK.
I KNOW THIS FOR MY OWN FAMILY
BECAUSE I HAVE REPUBLICANS IN MY
FAMILY.
YOU DON'T NEED TO ALWAYS BE
FINGER POINTING AND SCREAMING AT
EACH OTHER.
THERE ARE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES.
I THINK THIS SHOW IS GOOD NEWS
FOR EVERYBODY.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY HAS JACKIE.
THAT'S THE LEFT-WINGER, IN THEIR
FAMILY.
IF YOU HAVE A CONSERVATIVE YOU
MIGHT HAVE THAT.
IF YOU ARE A LIBERAL FAMILY, AND
I HAVE FRIENDS WHO HAVE
ROSEANNES AND THEIR FAMILY.
YOU ARE ROSEANNE, EXACTLY.
KIMBERLY, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
IT?
>> Kimberly: I THINK SHE IS
VERY FUNNY.
I HAVE ALWAYS ENJOYED HER COMEDY
AND SENSE OF HUMOR.
SHE IS BETTER AT ACTING THAN SHE
IS AT SINGING.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
SHE HAS MORE THAN MADE UP FOR
IT.
DEMONSTRATED HER PATRIOTISM FROM
HER LOVE FOR THE PRESIDENT ON
THE SHOW.
I THINK IT'S VERY INTERESTING
THAT YOU HAVE A LEAD IN A MAJOR
COMEDY SHOW THAT'S CONSERVATIVE,
AND IT WORKS.
MAYBE THE TELEVISION INDUSTRY
SHOULD PAY ATTENTION FROM THOSE
MONSTER READINGS, I THINK IT'S
FUN TO WATCH.
IT'S ONE TO WATCH IN TERMS OF
HOW THE SHOW ADDRESSES AND WHAT
RATING PATTERNS AND HISTORY AND
TRAJECTORY IT'S GOING TO BE.
>> Juan: JESSE SAYS THEY
DIDN'T DO POLITICS AND THE
SECOND SEGMENT.
MAYBE THEY ARE GOING TO BE LESS
POLITICAL.
I THOUGHT IT WAS FUNNY WHEN THEY
MADE FUN OF FAKE NEWS.
NOT ON A REAL NEWS CHANNEL.
>> Dana: I WAS THE SLOUCH THAT
WATCHED THE SECOND HOW ARE --
SECOND HALF HOUR.
IT WASN'T AS BLATANT IN TERMS OF
THE POLITICS THAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT ISSUES.
THE BULLYING THAT GOES ON FOR
THE GRANDSON AND HOW TO DEAL
WITH IT.
IT IS BEING UNDEREMPLOYED.
YOU WANT A JOB.
THERE IS 50 PEOPLE IN LINE TO
TRY TO GET THE JOB YOU WANT.
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS ARE
INTERESTING.
JENNIFER PALMIERI WHO WAS THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
HILLARY CLINTON, SHE WAS ON THE
2:00 SHOW TODAY.
SHE HAS A NEW BOOK OUT.
SHE TALKED ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE BOOK IS NOT JUST ABOUT WHY
SHE DIDN'T WIN BUT ROSEANNE
BARR, AND ONE OF THE PARTS SHE
SAYS I VOTED FOR HIM BECAUSE HE
TALKED ABOUT JOBS.
IT REALLY DOES COME DOWN TO
THAT.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT THOSE VERY
NARROW MARGINS IN WISCONSIN,
MICHIGAN.
I THINK PENNSYLVANIA WAS GONE
AWAY.
MICHIGAN AND WISCONSIN FOR SURE.
THAT NARROW SLICE, IF SHE HAD
JUST TALKED ABOUT JOBS MORE, IT
MIGHT'VE PUT HER OVER THE EDGE.
>> Juan: DID SHE SAY THE HOUSE
WAS AT RISK?
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, NOW WE ARE
IN THE FICTION WORLD.
DID THAT REALLY CHANGE THE
NUMBER OF JOBS?
THE WHOLE TONE IS BASED ON
ELGIN, ILLINOIS.
I DON'T SEE ALL OF A SUDDEN LEFT
BEHIND RUST BELT CITIES HAVE
BEEN REVIVED.
>> Dana: THESE TYPES OF
REUNION SHOWS DON'T ALWAYS WORK.
>> Greg: "FULLER HOUSE" WAS A
BOMB.
>> Dana: YOU WONDER WHAT
CHARACTERS YOU LIKED FROM 20
YEARS AGO.
WHAT WOULD THAT CHARACTER BE
LIKE TODAY?
>> Greg: "FRIENDS" WOULD BE
INTERESTING.
>> Dana: THERE WOULD BE ALL
SORTS OF THINGS GOING ON.
>> Kimberly: HERE WE GO RIGHT
HERE.
THIS IS THE NEW "FRIENDS."
SCHWIMMER OVER HERE.
>> Juan: IS ROSEANNE THE
ARCHIE BUNKER OF THE
21ST CENTURY?
>> Greg: I FEEL THIS SHOW IS
LIKE THE "ALL IN THE FAMILY," IT
HAS THAT FEELING AND THAT EVEN
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH ROSEANNE,
YOU STILL LIKE THE CHARACTER.
>> Kimberly: BUT YOU ARE
CALLING ROSEANNE BAR RACIST.
>> Juan: I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> Kimberly: THAT IS A BIG
CRITICISM OF THAT CHARACTER IN
THAT SHOW.
ARCHIE BUNKER.
LEVIED HEAVILY.
>> Juan: BUT THE JEFFERSONS
WERE HIS NEIGHBORS.
>> Greg: THEY WERE MOVING ON
UP.